six-foot-three fast and focused
freestyle swimmer Freya Anderson has
Tokyo in her sights
but like any typical 18 year old even
the Olympics will not separate her from
social media I know a few soon as I do
do that but that's not like how I go
about it I love social media and I love
to see what everyone's up to and keep in
touch with my friends and family so no I
definitely still be on it I probably
still Berlin for my race just checking
how everyone is but now I think yeah I
think I just like to stay in touch for
everyone and you know keep in the bubble
I guess really of the social media
before Christmas she unexpectedly won
two goals at the European short course
championships but the Olympics is her
live stream and if she makes it she'll
enjoy the pressure I get kind of excited
I think that's my sort of comfort zone
I'm definitely more comfortable standing
in front of tens of thousands of people
in a race suit than speaking in front of
ten or 20 people in a room I don't know
why that is I think it's just
Swimming's been my like comfort blanket
mr. pikna I really enjoy few days ago
Freya's on the fastest she's ever swung
at an international in Flanders picked
up three gold medals and it makes her
the third fastest Briton of all time it
is all going in the right direction
she's just a competitor she can she can
stand up in the race arena and that she
can compete and she can touch the wall
first better than anyone else I think
she can be on that podium I think we're
trying to point her in the right
direction and if that happens and
so--but if it doesn't then back to the
drawing board and she goes again but
with success comes the media spotlight
something she hasn't been comfortable
with I think I started to get used to it
now I quite enjoy doing the odd
interview I used to like if this was me
like four years ago
I then I could we did I couldn't do it
you know just be dead nervous and like
worrying about it for days before so now
it's just like all about just take it as
it comes really by the time the Olympics
start
Freya will have swum one and a half
thousand kilometres more on a cold
winter's morning here at Ellesmere
college pool that can be a challenge but
she knows there can be no shortcuts
sometimes it is definitely really hard
and I can't go without moaning but you
just have to keep your eyes on the prize
I guess especially with the Olympics
being so close but me personally I don't
want to be stood behind the blocks in
Tokyo if I make the team and having like
regrets that I didn't put everything I
could into the training so I think just
what I'm trying to go about is like just
don't hold anything back and who knows
in 182 days she could be making a splash
in more ways than one Jackie Bell trowel
Stein use Ellesmere